Speaker 1: Let's go next to. How about Enrique
from North Carolina, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. Yes. So starting company,
please. So my question is, do you know anything
about the features line up for that? No doctor?
Speaker 1: I mean, it's I've been saying for a
very long time that there we need a permanent
solution when it comes to Dako, it just we just
need it. It has to happen. But I am not aware.
I wish I could tell you, I think it's
coming soon. I don't really think it's
coming soon. I don't. Not this year, anyway.
Oh, yeah. Are you're at your adaka recipient?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I was born
here when I was one year old.
Speaker 1: Sorry. You were born here or
brought here at one year old. I miss that.
Speaker 4: Oh, I was brought here. One year
Speaker 1: old. That makes sense. Yeah,
most people are born at zero,
not at one. I figured I misheard.
Speaker 4: Oh, yes.
Speaker 1: And how old are you now? Yes.
Speaker 4: I'm 21 now.
Speaker 1: Wow,
so this is this is really your country.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah. I mean, I know more,
I'm more American than I am. I love I love Mexican
culture. I grew up in American culture. You know,
I speak English. This is America. Anyone here?
Speaker 1: For sure? Yeah. I mean, if if if
someone came to you and said, Sir, you've
got to go back to Mexico. I can only imagine
how devastating that would be.
Speaker 4: I would be freaking
out. I don't know what I would do.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, well, listen,
I'm with you. We need a solution. I hope that that
we get to it sooner than later. But realistically,
it doesn't seem like there's a political appetite
to get it done this this year at minimum.
Speaker 4: Now. All right, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you so much for
calling in. Yeah, I mean, you know, millions
of people in that situation, millions,
millions, it millions, maybe it's not now I
misremember, is it? Hundreds of thousands,
many people, many people. Let's go next to
Josie from Michigan. Josie, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: What's up, David? How are you doing?
How are you doing? Good. I just wanted to know,
what do you think about the 30 U.S. schoolchildren
still stuck in Afghanistan right now?
Speaker 1: I'm not aware of the number of
people left. What are the circumstances?
Were they on like some kind of summer
trip or something? Believe it or not,
Speaker 4: they were on a school
trip. I don't know who takes their
schoolchildren to Afghanistan.
Speaker 1: That's my question. I mean,
it's now I know that sometimes when people say,
how on earth would you take kids, people come
back and say, there's much to learn culturally.
Historically, I don't deny that. I don't deny
that. I just don't understand, given the security
situation, who who would do that? What age kids
are there. They high schoolers, do you know?
Speaker 4: I think I heard something along
the lines of one of the principal or one
of the students. Dad is a U.S. official or
something like that. And they were going, No.
Speaker 1: Have they? Do we know? I don't
know anything about the story. Have Joe Biden's
administration has said anyone who wants to get
out, we will help get out. There's no time limit
on it. Like, Are they are? Is there? Is this in
the middle of a process or what's going on?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's really hard to find
information on at this point
because even if you google it,
at this point, it only shows articles up to
like September 3rd and then there's been no
word on it since it's been mentioned, really?
Speaker 1: Is it possible they got out? But
there just haven't been articles
written because there's less of
a story once they're just back in the U.S..
Speaker 4: That's possible. I don't know. I
just thought it would be newsworthy.
You would think you would think.
Speaker 1: And I mean, listen, like I've said
before, we've got to support everybody who
wants to get out. Joe Biden said there's no time
limit. If you don't want to get out now and then
in a month, you do. He says the U.S. will help
and do everything that the government can, so
let's hope they stick to it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, let's hope.
All right. Good talking to you, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thanks for the
call. There's Jose from Michigan. A lot of lot
of good questions today. Let's try a different
country just for kicks. How about Fiona
from Germany? Fiona, you're on the air.
Speaker 8: Hello. I well thought about the
Afghanistan topic again. And we have data on
how much civilian support staff has been working
with the military. But the data has been collected
by civilian organizations and only made available
to government or listened to by the government as
recently as like the 10th of September. And
I would like to know the American situation.
Do you think that would be listened to if a
civilian organization would like mentioned
civilian support staff that may or may not be
interested in leaving Afghanistan? And if so,
would there be assistance rendered?
Speaker 1: I apologize. I'm not sure
I understand the question. You're saying the
American civilian support staff currently in
Afghanistan, is that who we're talking about?
Speaker 8: No civilian Afghan support staff that
happened to support European troops
is also been evacuated. How are you?
Very small situation and share.
Speaker 1: Are you listening to
some video in the background? I just
heard someone say, Hi, how are you?
No. Oh, that was weird. I don't know. I
mean, I don't know if they would qualify
for asylum or refugee status. I'm I'm
just not sure. It's very hard for me
to answer that question. I just don't know.
Speaker 8: Yeah, it's a convoluted thing. Yeah,
it just popped in my mind. But
thank you for calling on me.
Speaker 1: Oh, no problem.
How are things in Germany? OK?
Speaker 8: They have been very good, good.
Speaker 1: Excellent. I spent 24 hours
there last month and it was fantastic.
Speaker 8: Well. That's my fear. Yeah, I
hope to be back any of the political campaigning.
Speaker 1: And in Germany, no, I have not. No, I.
Speaker 8: It was very startling to me when
it appeared, and it was so tiny and small.
You didn't see that other countries.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, that's for sure.
All right. Thank you so much
for the call. OK, very good.